[Musique]
t'es sérieux là demain j'ai rendez vous
important à cette heure faut absolument
que je dorme et bah tu rentres pas je te
déteste vraiment la personne la plus
nulle du monde
j'espère bien
[Musique]
plus tu t'énerves - tu pourra entrer le
réveil
bassett dormir là attend quoi encore
tu peux me tenir un petit peu compagnie
peut-être ça m'aiderait à m'endormir je
te l'avais bien dit
enfin je dis ça je dis rien ben quoi
c'est pas ma faute
1 j'entends pages et des boules quiès
général à [ __ ]
[Musique]
tricheur
et pour aller travailler la montée on se
laisse moi juste cinq minutes encore 5
minutes premier volet on les connaît
toutes les cinq minutes
heureusement non allemande
[Musique]
séoul à la dure entre direct parce que
tu es complètement bourré mais demain
matin tu feras moins le malin
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il a il a pris de la drogue
justement voilà applique pas parfait
c'est quoi ce bruit on est dimanche je
t'ai pas vu le réveil banon
[Musique]
c'est bon t'as passé tous là bon bah
c'est le week-end tu peux me faire faire
une énorme insomnies c'est pas grave
demain j'ai rien je peux dormir toute la
journée
vas-y autre espèce de pâte à aa
ok demain j'ai un rendez-vous hyper
important pour moi la laisse moi entrer
au moins quelques heures s'te plaît ça
fait trois heures 6 devant j'en peux
plus j'ai épuisé bordel je dis non
[ __ ] j'arrête de penser à tout ça je
pense à rien quand je pense à rien je
pense quand même fait de ne pas penser
c'est un cercle vicieux technique et
c'est pas de m'énerver faut pas que mes
nerfs j'ai une idée
[Rires]
rendez vous
norman ouais qu'est ce que tu fais tu
arrêtes
[Musique]
norman
garrett ça
regarde répond tu te souviens à l'école
des petits camarades parce que tu avais
les cheveux frisés et appelait le mouton
basses alpes où ton
souvient way
hu
allez
sa chorale
essaye soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]